[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend wer
in diesen Tagen versucht für seine
erkranktes Kind Fiebersaft zu bekommen
kann ja eine regelrechte Odyssee erleben
das liegt vor allem daran dass im Moment
so ungewöhnlich viele Kinder
gleichzeitig krank und die Apotheken
regelrecht leer gekauft sind das Problem
reicht aber tiefer und betrifft nicht
nur Kinder und erkältungsmedikamente
über 300 Arzneimittel sind aktuell nicht
oder nicht ausreichend lieferbar
darunter auch Blutdrucksenker oder
Krebsmedikamente bei denen es nicht an
plötzlich gestiegener Nachfrage liegt
der Bundesgesundheitsminister erklärt
das unter anderem mit der Preispolitik
im deutschen Gesundheitssystem und will
gegensteuern Eltern die gerade
verzweifelt nach Hustensaft suchen wird
das aber so schnell nicht helfen Britta
Spiekermann berichtet
die A3 Apotheke im niederländischen
Dinxperlo an der Grenze zu
Nordrhein-Westfalen wer hier einkauft
will sich mit Medikamenten eindecken in
Deutschland ist vieles inzwischen
Mangelware
wenn man so ein hochfiebernes Kind hatte
man bekommt dann nichts es ist absolut
nicht nachvollziehbar wie viele Deutsche
kommen hier nach den Niederländer weil
wir haben die die Zäpfchen haben wir
noch und Kautabletten für die Kinder und
ja in Deutschland ich kann nicht mehr
verfügbar es soll ja sind doch manche
Leute komplett den Panik die Not ist
groß und aus der Not geboren das
Eckpunktepapier vom Minister Karl
Lauterbach wir haben derzeit in
Deutschland was die Arzneimittel
betrifft zwei wesentliche Probleme zum
einen an akutes versorgens Problem bei
der Versorgung von Kindern und zum
zweiten Lieferengpässe bei vielen
anderen Arzneimitteln für Kinder oder
auch für Erwachsene es wird zunehmend
eng auf dem deutschen Medikamentenmarkt
in Europa wurde die Produktion massiv
runtergefahren das Problem Krankenkassen
binden sich bei der Beschaffung häufig
nur an einen Hersteller meist an den
billigsten aus China oder Indien
Minister Lauterbach will jetzt dass die
Krankenkassen höhere Preise für knapper
Arzneimittel Zahlen am besten für in
Europa produzierte die zuständigen
Krankenkassen überrascht mit ihnen habe
der Minister noch gar nicht gesprochen
also ich gehe davon aus dass der
Minister eine Idee im Kopf hat wie er
das formal umsetzt aber ich habe bisher
keine solche Weisung oder Anweisungen
gesehen das muss ja dann auch
entsprechend formal geregelt werden ich
kenne diese Weisung nicht weiß die eine
Hand nicht was die andere will das
Bundesinstitut für Arzneimittel oberste
warmbehörde wenn es knapp wird weist auf
gestiegene Atemwegsinfektion hin und mit
Blick auf fiebersäfte das im Sommer
einer der größten Anbieter der
fraglichen Produkte die anstehende
Winter Bevorratung absagte schriftlich
fixiert Abhängigkeit Herr Spahn wollte
schon mit Beginn der corona-pandemie die
Arzneimittelproduktion wieder nach
Deutschland holen passiert ist leider
nicht und jetzt haben wir den Salat wir
haben im Moment 234 Lagerartikel die wir
nicht bekommen Besserung nicht in Sicht
und daran wird auch dieses Gesetz nichts
ändern
Liefer und auch
Versorgungsengpässe sind in Deutschland
nicht neu das jetzige Ausmaß ist es aber
sehr wohl schon fordern viele einen
Krisengipfel
und der Bundesgesundheitsminister ist
uns zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr
Lauterbach
diese Forderung nach einem Krisengipfel
zu medikamentenbeschaffung sind sie
dabei bringt das was nein wir müssen
jetzt handeln wir können uns keinen
Gipfel leisten wir wissen ja auch im
Prinzip was zu tun ist wir brauchen
schnelle Lösungen für die Kinder und die
müssen das Problem an der Wurzel
anfassen die Preise sind für die
Nachahmer Produkte in Deutschland zu
niedrig geworden da haben wir die
Preisschraube überdreht zu viele
Ökonomie somit was zu tun ist wissen wir
wir brauchen keinen Gipfel mehr
selbst wenn sie aber jetzt ich sag mal
die Fläschchen für so ein Fiebersaft den
Preis dafür verdoppeln würden könnten da
jetzt nicht plötzlich unzählige
Hersteller um ihre Produktion verdoppeln
also ich glaube bei Paracetamol haben
wir überhaupt Paracetamol Saft haben wir
überhaupt nur noch einen Anbieter also
wo soll es denn jetzt plötzlich
herkommen naja es wird schon noch
produziert und die Lieferung kommt auch
an aber sie kommt nicht in Deutschland
an die Preise sind im Ausland höher als
bei uns mittlerweile wir zahlen
mittlerweile mit die niedrigsten Preise
weil wir dieses Rabattsystem so
hochgedreht haben dass die Preise sehr
sehr niedrig sind daher wenn es knapp
wird wie jetzt in Europa viele Kinder
sind krank dann verkaufen die Händler
lieber in anderen europäischen Ländern
als in Deutschland war die magische dort
höher ist das heißt wir sind wirklich
die ersten wo gespart wird wenn es knapp
wird aber es ist noch Saft da wir
bekommen nur wenig und das hätte man
nicht schon früher erkennen können dass
ich da ein Problem anbahnt mit diesen
Preis drücken und staatlichen Eingriffen
und Rabattverträgen das ist richtig aber
das sind Dinge die sind seit vielen
Jahren liegen geblieben ich ich würde
sagen die Reform die wir jetzt machen
die ist seit zehn Jahren mindestens
notwendig weil das Problem ist ja jedes
Jahr schlimmer geworden und wir handeln
daher jetzt nicht nur was die Säfte für
Kinder angeht sondern wir gehen dann die
Wurzel heran wir verändern das
Rabattsystem insgesamt insbesondere auch
dahingehend dass wieder mehr in Europa
produziert werden kann und war dieses
Rabattsystem ja nicht einfach nur so
erfunden worden sondern es ging ja darum
Kosten einzusparen und am Ende dann auch
die Krankenkassenbeiträge niedriger
gehalten zu können wenn man jetzt wieder
mehr zahlt damit das Ganze attraktiver
ist für die Industrie und ist mehr
Medikamente gibt dann muss das Geld
dafür aber auch irgendwo herkommen wir
zahlen ja nicht für alles mehr wir haben
ja sehr hohe Preise bei den original
Präparaten die noch das Patent haben da
haben wir mit die höchsten Preise in
Europa wir haben nur eben sehr viel ich
sag mal ein Stück hat sogar kaputt
gespart bei den Generika Herstellern
weil da waren die Preise dann nachher so
niedrig dass dann nur noch ein Händler
meinetwegen aus China oder aus Indien
uns beliefern konnte jetzt wird das
etwas breiter aufgestellt dann das ist
immer noch nicht sehr teuer etwas teurer
aber das sind keine großen Beträge weil
das sind ja insgesamt die preiswerten
Arzneimittel wir machen es so dass
diejenigen die diese Rabattverträge
bekommen dass die einen Teil der
Lieferung auch aus Europa beschaffen
müssen und sie müssen sehr viel mehr
Lagerhaltung Nachweisen für ein paar
Monate Lagerhaltung dann ist das Problem
gelöst aber da muss jetzt dazu auch
erstmal genügend Medikamente geben damit
man sie lagern kann also wir haben ja
auch ein produktionsproblem offenbar ja
das produktionsproblem liegt daran dass
an der europäischer Hersteller jetzt von
uns nie den Zuschlag bekäme weil er
nicht billig genug ist und jetzt ändern
wir das Gesetz so dass also die
Krankenkassen auch einen europäischen
Anbieter nehmen müssen das heißt der
europäische Anbieter muss dann
tatsächlich berücksichtigt werden und
dann kommt die Produktion zurück aber
gibt es dann diese europäischen
Hersteller überhaupt in dieser Masse
also ich habe gelesen korrigieren Sie
mich Sie kennen sich daher besser aus
dass Ibuprofen fast komplett der
Wirkstoff aus China kommt und die
Produktion aus Indien
das ist so aber das ist der Sub so war
bisher eben die Preise so niedrig waren
dass man in Deutschland oder in Europa
nicht produzieren konnte wenn aber jetzt
die Krankenkassen auch mal Ware aus
Europa nehmen müssen bei etwas höheren
Preisen dann kommt die Produktion zurück
wir sehen das Problem schon lange wir
müssen einen Teil gerade der wichtigen
Wirkstoffe wieder in Europa produzieren
lassen da hilft nur der Zwang dass die
Krankenkassen dann auch aus Europa
kaufen müssen aber ein unterbrochenen
Lieferketten und an den Problemen die
jetzt zum Beispiel auch durch die
Pandemie und Lockdown sind China
entstanden sind wo eben sehr viel
produziert wird daran können wir ja
eigentlich wenig von hier aus ändern
oder ich meine in China sieht die
Situation ja gerade nicht so aus als
wird es da besser werden dann stellen
wir uns vor wir hätten das Gesetz dass
wir jetzt machen schon vor drei Jahren
beschlossen oder vor zwei Jahren die
Probleme sind ja schon alt dann hätten
wir jetzt auch europäische Produktion
und diese europäische Produktion könnte
uns dann beliefern das heißt es zeigt er
jetzt im Moment erst also wie sehr wir
einfach auf Risiko gegangen sind wir
hätten eigentlich schon vor zwei oder
drei Jahren so ein Gesetz gebraucht ein
Lauterbach danke für das Gespräch ich
danke Ihnen
scheint also so als hätten wir bei
Arzneimitteln einen ähnliches
Abhängigkeitsproblem wie bei der
Energieversorgung und nicht nur die
Pandemie auch der Krieg hat Lieferketten
beeinträchtigt heute ist der 300ste
Kriegstag 300 Tage Bombardierung
Beschuss Kämpfe
Präsidentin hat seine Truppen in bachmut
in der Ostukraine besucht und
ausgezeichnet ein gefährlicher von
Besuch die Russen stehen dort quasi vor
den Toren der Stadt sie ist einer der am
härtesten umkämpften Kriegsschauplätze
eine Brille ist derzeit unsere
Reporterin in der Ukraine und uns heute
Abend aus hackiv zugeschaltet eine die
Russen versuchen seit dem Sommer die
Stadt bachmut einzunehmen aber das
scheint ihnen bisher nicht zu gelingen
ja genau so ist es und das obwohl die
Russen massiv immer wieder Soldaten in
die Region verlegt haben auch Einheiten
der berüchtigten Söldnertruppe Wagner
das ist wirklich ein erbitterter
Stellungskrieg der da um bachmut tobte
Soldaten eingegraben in Schützengräben
Bildern wie man sie sonst aus dem ersten
Weltkrieg erkennt eine blutige
verlustreiche Schlacht für beide Seiten
Präsident selenski hat heute gesagt
99.000 russische Soldaten sind in diesem
Krieg getötet worden von den eigenen von
den ukrainischen Verlusten hat er nicht
gesprochen aber auch die sind in bachmut
sehr hoch warum ist denn bachmund so
wichtig also auch strategisch dass das
beide Seiten bereit sind dort so hohe
Verluste hinzunehmen
ja Stichwort Verluste die Russen mussten
ja tatsächlich in den letzten Monaten
viele Verluste hinnehmen gerade auch
hier in der Region hakif da hat die
ukrainische Armee ja im September eine
Gegenoffensive gestartet hat zahlreiche
Dörfer zurückerobert rasondern die Stadt
im Süden auch zurückerobert
bachmute liegt in der Region Don jetzt
dafür Russland ja schon seit 2014 damals
noch verdeckt Krieg und das russische
Ziel ist schon unbedingt diese Region
Don jetzt unter seine Kontrolle zu
bekommen und die Ukraine auf der anderen
Seite die Feiern zwei Erfolge die haben
mehr als 50% der Gebiete die die Russen
zu Anfang des Krieges besetzt hatten
zurückerobert allerdings auch zu einem
hohen Preis rasant zum Beispiel liegt
unter dauerhaftem Raketenbeschuss dann
gibt es diese
massivsten Angriffe auf die
Infrastruktur hier im ganzen Land mit
massiven Folgen für die Zivilbevölkerung
ähm das heißt für die Ukraine wäre
natürlich eine Sieg in bachmut auch ein
Signal nach innen ein sehr starkes
Signal und ein solches Signal wollte
Präsident selenski sicherlich heute auch
bei seinem Besuch dort in der Region
setzen danke Ihnen für diese Einordnung
Wladimir Putin war übrigens noch kein
einziges Mal an der Front er verteilte
heute Orden im Kremmen
der Wahl organisierende Europäer weiter
ihre Unterstützung für die Ukraine und
ihre eigene Verteidigung die deutsche
Verteidigungsministerin ist dazu gerade
in der Slowakei Heinz er
Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht war
dort zum Abschluss ihrer Reise bei einer
Bundeswehreinheit die 250 Soldatinnen
und Soldaten gehören zu einer NATO
Kampftruppe die nach dem russischen
Einmarsch in die Ukraine in der Slowakei
stationiert worden ist Lamprecht zeigt
dir das Slowakei weitere Unterstützung
bei der Luftverteidigung zu zwei
deutsche Patriot flugabwehrstaffeln sind
bereits dort stationiert
in Afghanistan verbieten die
islamistischen Taliban Frauen die
universitätsbildung in einer
Regierungserklärung wurden alle privaten
und öffentlichen Universitäten
angewiesen das bildungsverbot für Frauen
bis auf weiteres durchzusetzen die
Taliban haben seit ihrer Machtübernahme
im August 2021 die Frauenrechte massiv
eingeschränkt
in der Diskussion über die künftige
Wertermittlung von Immobilien und die
höheren Kosten die dadurch auf Erden
zukommen können weil Bayern nun Klage
beim Bundesverfassungsgericht einreichen
das halte die Landesregierung nach einer
Kabinettssitzung mit zur Begründung hieß
es dass die Freibeträge bei der
Erbschaftsteuer seit 2009 unverändert
sein während die Preise für Immobilien
in weiten Teilen Bayerns deutlich
gestiegen sein das Stelle Erben Vorteils
massive finanzielle Probleme
die abgesetzte Vizepräsidentin des
Europaparlaments evakaili die vor 11
Tagen wegen Korruptionsvorwürfen
verhaftet wurde soll laut
Medienberichten ein Teilgeständnis
abgelegt haben demnach soll sie unter
anderem zugegeben haben dass sie ihren
Vater angewiesen habe Geld in Sicherheit
zu bringen am Donnerstag will die
belgische Justiz entscheiden ob Kylie
weiter in Untersuchungshaft bleiben muss
die Angeklagte hatte im Vorfeld gezeigt
wie Sie zu diesem Verfahren steht am
ersten Verhandlungstag im September
letzten Jahres versuchte sie mit einem
Taxi zu flüchten
offenkundig war sie nicht bereit sich
als Mittäterin zu verantworten 77 Jahre
nach den Verbrechen im kz-stutthof an
den sie beteiligt war ich war doch nur
die Sekretärin oder ich war doch nur ein
Wachmann
jahrzehntelang wurden solche Mittäter
nicht zur Rechenschaft gezogen generell
war die deutsche Justiz zurückhaltend
bei der Aufarbeitung des Nazi-Terrors
und seiner Helfer das hat sich erst seit
kurzem geändert was aber auch dazu führt
dass es nur noch wenige Angeklagte gibt
und diese nunmehr im Kreisen Alter vor
Gericht stehen
sarattacke über den heutigen
Urteilsspruch und seine Hintergründe
ich lebe zwei Leben nicht einen ich lebe
mein Leben am Tag
und lebe mein Leben nachts
nachts wenn ich immer noch im Lager
was aber na Ohr hier damals erlebte im
Konzentrationslager Struthof kann er
nicht vergessen
wenn ich gesehen habe meine Mutter und
den kleinen Jungen und noch eine andere
Frau mit Kinder wusste ich genau
wurde hingehen wusste ich genau ich
hätte das letzte Mal
die Liste auf den die Namen seiner
Mutter und seines Bruder standen die
Liste mit den Namen der Opfer hat sie
abgetippt
Irmgard furchtner sie war die Sekretärin
des Lagerkommandanten damals 18 19 Jahre
alt deshalb verurteilte sie heute diese
Jugendkammer des Landgerichts Itzehoe zu
zwei Jahren auf Bewährung wieso jetzt
fragen viele
erst jetzt durch eine Änderung der
Rechtsprechung vor wenigen Jahren ist es
möglich auch sogenannte kleine Rädchen
im großen Betrieb des massenmordens vor
Gericht zu stellen und genau deshalb ist
dieses Urteil von heute von so immenser
Bedeutung weil es auch zeigt was die
deutsche Justiz über Jahrzehnte versäumt
hat Täter Helfer Helfershelfer vor
Gericht zu stellen und es zeigt dass
jeder der einen Beitrag geleistet hat
für das Massenmorden auch verantwortlich
ist
diese Änderung in der Rechtsprechung
kommt spät zu spät sagt uns heute aber
nur als wir in der Nähe von Tel Aviv
treffen er sieht den Prozess sehr
kritisch
ich suche Menschlichkeit
warum hat man gewartet so lange
hatte große Fische laufen lassen und
jetzt sucht man eine Frau mit 96
eine Täterin die als Jugendliche
mitgeholfen hat das Morden im KZ zu
organisieren wenn Emre nicht in Berufung
geht ist die Aufarbeitung ihrer Schuld
mit dem Urteil heute abgeschlossen aber
na Ohr kann niemals abschließen
ich bin vom Lager nicht befreit worden
aber der lagere ich in mir ein ganzes
Leben
und trotzdem ist der versöhnt
ich habe längst mit Deutschland Frieden
gemacht
das ist ganz neu in Deutschland ist ein
neues Land für mich die Menschen sind
andere Menschen
und eine andere Justiz die endlich
Schuldfragen aufarbeitet die sie
Jahrzehnte nicht gestellt hat
und Vergangenheitsbewältigung ging es
heute auch beim Besuch der deutschen
Außenministerin in Nigeria sie hatte
wertvolle wertvolle Kulturgüter im
Gepäck 20 Benin Branchen um deren
Rückgabe Nigeria jahrzehntelang
vergeblich gebeten hat bislang lagerten
sie in deutschen Museen zum Beispiel in
Berlin Dresden oder Köln über den Umgang
mit der sogenannten Raubkunst wird ja
seit langem diskutiert
Kulturstaatsminister und Claudia Roth
sprach heute von einem Wendepunkt in der
internationalen Kulturpolitik aber um
Kultur allein geht es dabei wohl nicht
es passt auch zum Bemühen der deutschen
Außenpolitik die Beziehungen zu den
Ländern des afrikanischen Kontinents zu
verbessern Andrea Maurer berichtet
die deutsche Außenministerin gibt in
Nigerias Hauptstadt etwas zurück das
Deutschland nie gehört hat und doch über
ein Jahrhundert in seinem Besitz war 20
von über 1.100 Benin Branchen aus
deutschen Beständen einen Anfang
es war falsch diese Bronzen zu stehlen
es war falsch diese Bronzen zu behalten
und es ist mehr als überfällig dass
diese Bronzen in ihrer Heimat
zurückkommen auch die
kulturstaatsministerin ist mit nach
Nigeria gekommen rot reist in den Süden
des Landes nach beninity Hauptstadt des
früheren Königreichs Benin
1897 vielen britische Truppen hier ein
plünderten die Kunstschätze verkauften
sie an Museen in ganz Europa wer nicht
nach Europa reisen konnte hat die
Branchen die seit dem 16 Jahrhundert den
Königspalast schmückten nie gesehen bis
heute gießen Sie hier Nachbildungen der
verlorenen Kunstschätze
wurden zur Zeit meines Urgroßvaters
gestohlen ich habe das bronzegießen von
meinem Großvater gelernt ich werde sehr
glücklich sein die echten Bronzen
endlich zu sehen
es kommt nicht oft vor dass die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen für die deutsche
kulturstaatsministerin so hoch sind wie
bei diesem Besuch die Gefahr von
Anschlägen ist in Nigeria allgegenwärtig
rot Euphorie aber überwiegt
es ist unglaublich emotional und
man sagt ja manchmal oh das ist
Geschichte oder das ist ein historische
Moment und ich glaube tatsächlich dass
die Reise und das was wir mitbringen
historisch ist denn wir bringen Menschen
eine Gesellschaft etwas zurück was ihre
kulturelle Identität ist so
symbolträchtig die Reise so schwierig
ist die Lage in Nigeria hier wo das
öffentliche Museum für die Branchen
stehen soll dass Deutschland mit
finanziert bisher nur Schlamm und
baulöcher auch die Königsfamilie von
Benin erhebt private Ansprüche auf die
Branchen der amtierende Gouverneur weiß
sie zurück
vergessen Sie nicht vor 125 Jahren als
die Branchen gestohlen wurden gab es den
Staaten Nigeria noch nicht die Briten
haben das Königreich zerstört nigeria
ist entstanden dieses nigeria ist nun
der rechtmäßige Eigentümer der Schütze
erklären die Branchen nun auch Heim in
ein Land voller Konflikte Korruption
ungeklärte Eigentumsrechte und ein
massives Sicherheitsproblem das ist
während der gesamten Reise
offensichtlich was mit den Benin
Branchen in Nigeria passiert darauf hat
Deutschland keinen Einfluss mehr die
Branchen gehören Deutschland nicht mehr
rechtmäßig gehört aber hat die Raubkunst
Deutschland ohnehin nie
und jetzt noch mal andere Nachrichten
von Heinz Wolf
Bundespräsident Steinmeier hat China
Staatspräsidenten Ski gebeten seinen
Einfluss auf Russland zu nutzen und sich
bei chemisches Putin für ein Ende des
Krieges gegen die Ukraine einzusetzen
der kriegsstand neben den bilateralen
Beziehungen und der aktuellen
corona-lage in China im Mittelpunkt
eines rundeinstündigen Telefonats
zwischen Steinmeier und hi anders dafür
war das 50 Jubiläum der bilateralen
Beziehungen und jetzt der Blick auf
Chinas Wirtschaft zu der zuletzt
schwache Wachstumszahlen kamen so in der
Konjunktur Einschätzung der Weltbank
Valerie welche Folgen kann das für die
deutsche Wirtschaft haben keine guten
Berliner ist ja schließlich der zweit
die zweitgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt
und wenn ein solcher Riese schwächelt
dann hat das natürlich globale
Auswirkungen besonders für Deutschland
dessen Wirtschaft ja stark vom Export
abhängt Beispiel Autoindustrie für sie
ist China der wichtigste Absatzmarkt
Mercedes und BMW verkaufen über ein
Drittel ihrer Fahrzeuge in China ja und
Volkswagen sogar noch mehr nun sieht die
Weltbank erhebliche Risiken für Chinas
Konjunktur im Fokus vor allem die
Pandemie aus Angst sich anzustecken
bleiben viele Chinesen zu Hause der
Konsum bricht ein außerdem hält die
Immobilienkrise an der Bausektor macht
immerhin ein Viertel der gesamten
Wirtschaftsleistung aus viele Bauträger
kämpfen ums Überleben infolgedessen
senkt die Weltbank ihre
Wachstumsprognose 2022 für China
drastisch von 4,3% auf nun mehr 2,7 %.
um die Konjunktur anzukurbeln hat die
chinesische Regierung massiv in die
Infrastruktur investiert Zinsen gesenkt
und steuerrabatte gewährt all das
verpufft durch die
corona-infektionswelle China bekommt nun
auch wirtschaftlich mit voller Wucht die
Folgen einer verfehlten corona-politik
zu spüren Valeria Haller vielen Dank
vom Bundesarbeitsgericht kommt ein
Grundsatzurteil zum Anspruch auf Urlaub
der verfällt demnach nicht automatisch
nach einer dreijährigen Verjährungsfrist
vielmehr müssen Arbeitgeber Ihre
Beschäftigten auf Urlaubsansprüche
hinweisen und darauf dass sie verfallen
können erfüllen sie diese Pflicht nicht
bleiben die Ansprüche bestehen
in Großbritannien wird das Bild des
neuen König Charles des dritten in
Zukunft auf Geldscheinen zu sehen sein
die neuen 5 10 20 und 50 Pfund Scheine
werden ab übernächsten Jahr ausgegeben
so die Bank of England die alten
Geldscheine mit dem Bild von Königin
Elisabeth II bleiben aber weiter gültig
die einen haben einen König die anderen
haben Messi den Fußballgott wenn
Weltmeister samt Pokal in ihr Heimatland
zurückkehren werden sie natürlich immer
frenetisch gefeiert aber in Argentinien
hat das noch mal andere Ausmaße 5
Millionen sollen allein in Buenos Aires
auf der Straße sein Ralf panicek über
ein Land im Ausnahmezustand
sie feiern und wie
Argentiniens Weltmeister auf dem Bus wie
rodride Paul auf dem Weg in die
Innenstadt
und mit ihnen etwa fünf Millionen
Menschen auf den Straßen von Buenos
Aires
ein Tag an dem keiner arbeiten muss ein
Tag für die Herzen und die Geschichte
Bücher
der Titel ist eine Streicheleinheit für
die Menschen hier was die Spieler uns
gegeben haben ist eine Liebkosung für
das Volk das ist schön sehr sehr schön
ich habe so lange darauf gewartet und
jetzt hat es geklappt ich bin einfach
nur glücklich
der Titel hat uns alle Argentina
zusammengebracht meine Tochter wird
heute 18 und ihr Traum weiß die Spieler
zu sehen
mitten in der Nacht kamen sie an kam der
Pokal wieder nach Argentinien gegen zwei
Uhr 30 in den Händen von Lionel Messi
ein Team ein Land ein Traum pathetisch
das Logan ihrer Heimreise doch er trifft
schon in der Nacht warteten zigtausende
auf diesen Moment und sie alle feierten
mit möchten den Moment festhalten in
keinem anderen Land gilt fußball ist
hier eine Religion die Helden gleichen
Heiligen und der kleinste ist der größte
Lionel Messi postete von der kurzen
Nacht die ihm blieb ein Foto von sich
und dem Pokal ein kurzer Moment der Ruhe
Messi und der Pokal schon früher Morgen
strömen die Menschen in die Innenstadt
um das erleben zu können aus dem ganzen
Land kommen sie außer zu Fuß bewegt sich
fast nichts mehr auf den breiten Straßen
der Hauptstadt Ziel der meisten der
Obelisk im Zentrum
stundenlang feiern Sie hier fröhlich
ausgelassen während sie warten und
überall tragen Sie das Trikot von Messi
die Nummer 10 vereint im Erfolg die
Probleme weit weg von denen die meisten
viel zu viele haben doch nicht an diesem
Tag
etwa 30 Kilometer sollte die Fahrt des
offenen Busses mit den Spielern lang
sein sie bleibt jedoch früh stecken
durch die Masse an Fans kommt der Bus
nicht durch
Helikopter müssen die Spieler daraus
holen die jubelfahrt endet als kurzer
Flug über die Massen an einem Tag an dem
sich alle Argentinier als Weltmeister
fühlen
[Musik]
diesen Bildern verabschieden wir uns mit
der Anstalt geht es gleich weiter
schon mal Update mit Christopher
Wehrmann Morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter regnerisch bleibt
es in den nächsten Tagen und das
aktuelle Regengebiet das zieht
allmählich ostwärts und auch nach
Südosten morgen im Tagesverlauf ja da
wird es kurz mal trocken sein bevor der
nächste Ring von Westen dann aufzieht in
der Nacht gefriert dieser Regen Richtung
Vogtland bis ins Erzgebirge ansonsten
gibt es viele Wolken und Regen nach
Norden hinnebel genauso wie im Südosten
Deutschlands und dort ist es am
kältesten mit Temperaturen von -3 bis 0
Grad ganz im Westen am mildesten mit 9
Grad plus morgen am Vormittag gibt's
weiterhin Glatteis durchgefrieren in
Regen im Südosten Deutschlands auch
Richtung Erzgebirge wieder ansonsten
viele Wolken mit Regen von Westen her
wird es allmählich trockener ja und zum
Nachmittag verabschiedet sich der Regen
weiter in den Osten dazwischen ist das
Trocken zum Nachmittag und Abend dann
neuer Regen aus westlichen Richtungen
dazu Temperaturen mit höchsten Werten
von 1 bis 4 Grad in Bayern 10 Grad am
Niederrhein und 12 Grad Richtung
Oberrhein ziemlich mild die nächsten
Tage am Donnerstag viel Regen kräftiger
Wind aus südwestlichen Richtungen
Temperaturen drei bis 14 Grad am Freitag
wird es noch milder Werte bis 16 Grad
dazu stürmisch im Süden und in der Mitte
und Heiligabend Temperaturen bis 13 Grad
und weiterer Regen damit ein schöner
Abend